and the dodgers are going to get plenty
of miles michael is here in game one
forcing fastball to seem basically a lot
of fast balls and sliders when he was
successful before he got hurt it was
fastball fastball fastball an occasional
breaking ball he was great with location
trey turner standing in michaelis deals
and turner hits one in the left center
field
o'neal sprinting to the gap won't get
there bounces into the seats a lead-off
double for trey turner that's as good as
a cup of coffee for a lineup that didn't
get much rest extend his hitting streak
now to
13 games runners at first and third and
nobody out hooky bets with an rbi
opportunity here 1-1
it's sharply down the line bases it for
bets
three consecutive hits to open the day
turner can walk home to third goes
muncie
it's one nothing just like that 20th
pitch of this inning coming up for miles
michaelis who's still looking for his
first hour
turner sends one to second edmond feeds
sosa takes his time throws the first to
double play
they want to come to the back door two
nothing dodgers chris taylor on his way
to the plate
hits this wall of time left center field
way back and gone
chris corner with a two-run blast
and the dodgers with a full end first
after getting to bed at four in the
morning who needs sleep
forcing fastball near the middle of the
play that he does not miss dodgers
canceled batting practice to give the
guys a chance to sleep a little longer
fiction in his hometown a st louis
native in his 14th big league year and a
guy that of course has three cy youngs
already has a career best 240 era the
six starts with the dodgers have been
amazing 4-0 with a 1-2-9 show man on for
paul goldschmidt here's his 2-2
got him two to go to get to 200 one down
in the bottom of the first dylan carlson
the right fielder
oh and he got him looking at a curveball
strike three on a 3-2 count you gotta
wonder what carlson was looking at
because that was a pretty good pitch the
whole way so big strikeout with the
runner at third and one gone and it's up
to tyler o'neill swung on and missed
strike three and that is strikeout
number 200
on the season
for max scherzer pitch to emundo sosa
the shortstop 2-2 to sosa swung on foul
tipped into the glove of austin barnes
for strikeout number four for scherzer
201 on the season 200 second and two
down dodgers up four nothing
ground ball
base it into center
bets into score as seeger drives in a
run with two gone and they lead five
nothing scherzer's retired sixth
straight since tommy edmund's lead off
double
grounded to third for turner
one away in the third and now he faces
michaelis
who swings away hits the line to the
left for taylor
two up and two down back to the top for
edmond scherzer kneeling
and striking him out 97 right past him
strikeout number five on the afternoon
for max scherzer bottom of the fourth
inning one on and nobody out dylan
carlson
bouncing ball to second turner turns
guns to second one to first but not in
time carlson aboard in the fielder's
choice one going so one on one out for
tyler o'neal
pop flying to right field for mookie
bentz
two out
here's carpenter laid off single for
goldschmidt runner still at first with
two gone
and a good change up taken for ball one
oh he went around carpenter goes around
and shows her gets his
sixth strike out of the game
the ground ball raked to third carpenter
has it his throw just beats trey turner
one pitch and one out this is muncie 3-2
pitch and muncie hits it out to deep
left backing up and making the catch
will be tyler o'neill pitch number 90
for michaelis
it's sharply to third carpenter there
and he'll make the play four on first
inning the big one in this game dodgers
add one in the third and four zeros put
up there by max scherzer's giving up
just two base runners through these four
innings
lifted right for bets
who's got it
another quick out
harrison bader
chases good morning good afternoon and
good night for max serzer to sit down
bader 7k for scherzer two out in the
fifth
chopper to third justin turner
that is another very quick inning for
scherzer
3-2 pitch by miller got him he wins that
battle the strikeout for andrew miller
in his return
13 pitch at bet
and a high fly ball
into right battling the sun dylan
carlson with the catch
here's the pitch there's a swing and a
drive into center field right to
harrison bader he makes the catch max
scherzer now steps into the shadow a
pinch hitter in the pitcher's spot
left-handed hitter lars newt barr
strikes out newt park eight strikeouts
for max scherzer cardinals are their
best chance of the game first and third
one gone hitters carlson and goldschmidt
have gone to combine four for six rest
of the lineup over 14.
check swing
he went around strikeout number nine for
scherzer runners at the corners and two
down and the left fielder tyler o'neal
over two at the plate
gets away
and here comes edmond trying to score
and he's safe throw may have beat him
but i'm not sure the tag was there and i
think that is the right call
i think that this is a tough play for a
pitcher because when you go to tag
somebody you see the plate so you go
straight down and sometimes you forget
that there's the front of the plate the
call is safe edmond scores on a pass
ball down to second paul goldsmith
[Applause]
he's right there called strike three
strikeout number ten and scherzer has
2991
in his career the bottom of the seventh
inning where max scherzer goes back to
the mall with 10 strikeouts already
strikeout number 11 for scherzer
those 11 k's for scherzer his most as a
dodger second most this season outside
of the 14 strikeout game at yankee
stadium the o2 pitch coming to kisner
he strikes out swinging
foul tip into the glove of barnes that's
a dozen strikeouts
for max scherzer this afternoon he's
gone seven strong to the eighth inning
turns her back out there with 12 k's
under his belt is one two
a change change-up disappears and he's
got 13 today
the respective mounds there's a shot on
a hop to
trey turner
turner makes the play at first base and
edmond is out two gone and he kept the
lie for dylan carlson 1-1 pitch now to
carlson
and he grounds one to the right side
turner in the outfield grass grabs it
throws onto first
and carlson is out and the side retired
one hit one left but max scherzer eight
full innings
has done the job and then some today
cardinals down to their last out at
mundo so-so one for three
softbouncer left side easy play seaguar
and a win for the dodgers in the opener
in saint louis
5-1 the final score right in the
four-run first inning
you